so so far so good now i'm ready to
actually uh quote what integration by
parts tells me about i
sub m uh just to prop my memory it's
going to be uv
minus the integral of v d u so it's just
a bit of a straight substitution here so
let's have a go
this is a definite integral so i'm going
to put my big square brackets here
here comes u it's
x to the m minus 1. and then v is going
to be
a 12
x squared minus one to the power of six
and remember what my boundaries are from
the question it's from naught to one um
just before i do the other half of
integration by parts you can see how
this question was clearly crafted to
make things kind of nice for us right
when you put that top boundary in
remembering this is all one product you
can see in this term this factor one
take away one gives you zero so this
whole
expression which looks disastrous once
you put in the top boundary it's gone
once you put in the bottom boundary well
you've got this x term right so 0 to the
power of n minus 1 is 0. so it's also
going to come out in the wash so that's
nice i'll just keep that in mind for
later
let's do the rest of the integration by
part so i'm integrating now v d u so it
looks to me like i've got um this is
going to be a little messy but stay with
me here's the v
uh that's done and then here comes the d
u so it's m minus 1 x to the m minus 2
dx and like i said before this this term
right here
x to the n minus 2 um you should
recognize that right you're like i need
that that's got to come in somewhere so
this is already a really good sign just
confirming what we had before
okay where can we progress with this
it's sort of downhill from here i think
we've actually done the hardest part of
this question and i don't know i wasn't
part of the hsc marking back then but i
reckon anyone who got to this point
i reckon this was kind of like the the
24 of people who got this question right
because the rest of it you just have to
be careful with your algebra and your
calculus so let's have a go shall we
as explained earlier you're just going
to get zero from the substituting in the
top and the bottom boundaries there
i'm now subtracting this integral and i
do notice if you have a look carefully
1 over 12 that's a constant
m minus 1 also a constant in this
context because remember i'm integrating
with respect to x so therefore i'm just
going to pull all of that out the front
of the integral
as my constant coefficient so choose the
right color would be helpful m minus 1
on 12. what happens when you put them
together
i'm integrating from 0 to 1 and then i
get x squared minus 1 to the 6
x to the minus 2
and you know what i should probably put
that in a more helpful order remembering
um what i m was laid out for us in um
you have the x term first and then you
have this x squared minus one stuff
later so that's
all integrated with respect to x okay
um so what do i do with this well i can
keep on going um i can i still have this
minus i'll put that in brackets so i
don't accidentally
blend it into that fraction line there
which
i have definitely done a bunch of times
let's have a look at this expression
this integrand that we have here right
so item number one you've got x to the m
minus two tick i wanted that but then
you've got x squared minus 1 to the 6.
and when you have a look back no matter
whether you've got i m or i n minus 2 or
i n minus 3 or anything right you never
get an x squared minus 1 to the power of
6. you only ever get it to the power of
five right that is constant it's
independent of m like we were mentioning
before so therefore when i look at this
line i need to break out one of those x
squared minus ones one of those x
squared minus ones has to be factored
out to leave me with an x squared minus
one to the 5.
that is going to complicate things a
little bit but there's no other way that
i can get this in terms of the i m that
we were given before okay
so here's the way i'm going to do it i'm
going to call this
term out the front the same i've got
this and i'm factoring out one of the x
squared minus ones and then i'll write
this in some other colors so that we can
distinguish this a little bit i'm going
to get an x squared
and then i'm going to get a minus 1. and
the reason why i'm writing them
separately is because i have no choice
i'm gonna have to break this apart into
two separate integrals uh but that's
okay that's part of what is actually
gonna make the algebraic manipulation
work
all right we are we're on the downhill
now so i'm gonna take this
constant coefficient just chuck it out
the front
and then what comes inside these
ridiculously large brackets well
i'm first going to multiply everything
through by x squared so it'll be x
squared times our x term and our x
squared minus 1 to the 5 term so i'll do
that in green so you can follow where
that integral is so 0 to 1.
now when you multiply this by x squared
just look at the indices right this is
index laws so i can say i'm adding the
indices together since the bases are the
same so the two and the minus two they
cancel that's convenient so i'm just
going to get x to the m and i've got x
squared minus one to the five so there
you go there's the first integral that
we got from breaking that apart
and then i go again with minus one and
everything here just comes out unchanged
so it's still from not to one
that x to the m minus two i haven't done
any weird index laws with that x squared
minus one to the five
dx and that's everything there right
okay well done uh how do i how do i
disentangle this right well remembering
that you've got i m over here on the
left right so i can actually say i can
start to identify being that this looks
familiar like have a look at that
compare that to the question that looks
to me like it's exactly i am
and then this is the im -2 that we uh
let me scroll back up that we wrote
beforehand just so we can knew where we
would be able to identify it right so
therefore i'm going to try and simplify
this out that fraction is bothering me
i've left it there for long enough so
i'll multiply both sides by 12.
there are 12 ims over there
i've got a minus m minus one okay uh
what happens in green here well we'll
follow that along that's i am
and then i've got another um careful
with the minus signs here that minus is
going to cancel with that minus so i'm
going to get a plus
and then you've got
m minus 1 lots of not i am but i am
minus 2. so i'll write that in
like so
and now i'm so close right you can sort
of see because you know your destination
right essentially what we're trying to
get is i am
in terms of i am minus two so we're
going to make this the subject um i need
to collect some like terms and all that
kind of thing and there's quite a few
over here right so how many ims will i
end up with on the left hand side and i
mean you can slightly cheat at this
point because they're so close to the
end i'm going to add an m to both sides
so i've got well not an m and m lots of
i am so i'm adding it there so i'm going
to factorize it out here and then i'm
also going to add a negative 1
lot of im to both sides so when you add
that to the 12 you're getting 11 of them
that 11 looks suspiciously familiar
that's something that we're going to
need
uh on the right hand side you just have
this m minus 1 on i m minus 2 and i
should have pointed out earlier but
that's kind of exactly what i wanted
right see that m minus 1 up there so
that's exactly in the right spot i don't
need to manipulate it any further and
our final line is to divide through
m minus 1
m plus 11
and
you can put a nice neat bow on top of it
as required
full stop okay so i hope you found that
helpful i hope it was clear and for
those of you who haven't done a
recurrence relation for a while um that
it was a good refresher for you